Jamshed akbari always loved basketball
back home in Afghanistan he used to
coach a women's team professionally
the income comfortably sustained Jamshed
and his family
basketball is my life and was my
greatest passion I'd reached the
national level I worked as a coach and
coached a women's basketball team
but the Taliban banned women's sports
Jamshed managed to flee Afghanistan just
in time thanks to assurances from the
Canadian government but after a few
weeks in Qatar he got stuck in Albania
as Canada wouldn't take him in he's now
hoping for a U.S visa
he shows us pictures of his family who
he had to leave behind his twins are
just over a year old now he hasn't seen
them since they were newborns
then his wife calls
I am giving a television interview
I will talk about my problems loneliness
the family the bureaucracy
I swear all I do here is wait
ing
over the past year everyone told me I
had been extremely lucky
because I was able to leave my country
and reach Albania in Europe
and that we are on route to Canada or
America but I think I'm the unhappiest
of all the unhappy people here
over a year has passed since U.S forces
flew thousands of Afghans out of the
country following the Taliban takeover
U.S Aid agencies asked Albania a poor
country to take in 2500 refugees
the refugees were brought to a hotel in
the resort town of Shenzhen their stay
was supposed to be a stopover but 700
Afghans remain here stuck among
sunbathing tourists
with each day that passes the United
States promised to take them in rings
hollower
ahanita hadari and her sister were
active in Afghanistan's women's movement
for years they can't go back while the
Taliban is in power but there isn't a
clear Way Forward for them either
we were promised that all Afghan
refugees would be transferred from
Albania to Canada or the U.S within two
to three months
to date that hasn't happened and it
makes us worry
we asked the U.S embassy in Albania for
an interview
but we're told to contact the U.S state
Department in Washington
but even though we did several times we
didn't get a response
we head for the Albanian Capital Tirana
to interview prime minister Eddie Rama
Albania after all counted on the U.S
taking in the Afghan refugees
yeah I understand them but the time is
going
and we don't have the feeling that
the U.S
Administration is processing them we
have the feeling that
they are here to stay anyhow
they cannot stay forever in the hotel
and they have to start and build a life
Albania however is a poor country with
high unemployment those who can leave
the Afghan refugees are worried they'll
remain stuck in Albania a few months ago
they staged their first protests and
ajanita joined them
as you can see Albania is a poor country
we enjoy greater safety here than in
Afghanistan but that is all
as refugees we have no opportunities for
education employment or any other kind
of development in this country
jump sheet has almost stopped caring All
That Matters to him is reuniting with
his family
given these circumstances life is better
in Albania and I would stay
even so Jamshed still dreams of making a
new life in the U.S together with his
family but with each passing day his
hopes slowly fade